I thought we begin by talking very
briefly about the document whose
discovery gave rise to the research and
then about two of the major interpretive
questions who exploration we hoped would
be made possible by following this trail
and then I'll close with maybe a brief
word about using a family itinerary to
examine certain dimensions of creative
imagination so the project began really
with pieces of paper that looks to be
over the place the boxes in the
cuban-american alarm clock that hold the
incoming correspondence directed to
general Maximo Gomez who was one who
uses the human word dependence in 1899
who was probably and as you know Spain
had been expelled from humor by the
efforts of the world independence of the
United States that occupied the island
and was really an under military chapter
and many ordinary Cubans wrote to
general Gomez from various places the
countryside describing their distress
and pointing their difficulties and so I
was working my way through these boxes
of letters trying to capture a sense of
vernacular understandings of right
independence but in one of these boxes
there was an incongruous document but
typed with a purple typewriter ribbon on
the letterhead of a Belgian sitting
right there intermixed with all these
letters and it begins that I'll read you
just a sentence or two that the letter
begins in early and our sympathy with
human cause I've been always a pride
myself in being still one of the most
sincere and fighters this is how you
begin a letter in my backside so I would
be highly honored you have the kindness
to authorize me use your illustrious
name for Brandon of my best articles
your portrait adorning believe aware of
an approved copy is enclosed so the
first two sentences is a completely
routine commercial request by a cigar
maker of wants to put a famous Cuban on
his cigars which are manufactured from
Mexican tobacco innovation Factory room
so if an archivist had been going
through this systematic that they might
have tossed this letter out because they
would consider the routine request but
the writer of the letter goes on to say
I may not be altogether unknown to some
of the survivors of the last struggle
referring to court independence say even
a humble but stay contributor that
you've been fun many of
holy man perhaps they remember me and
here's where for those of you who are
angry us money begins to claim as a
member a company c6 Louisiana volunteers
banks division in 1863 so suddenly the
Velvet cigar maker has become a Union
soldier American Civil War as a
representative of the sixth Ward that's
committee of the city of New Orleans and
the Constitutional Convention was
Louisiana in 1868 and as para comer
knows and when anyone that is correctly
my wrong pretty much the most radical
state convention have those members of
men of color that produces one of the
most extraordinary state constitutions
of the century guarantee is absolutely
full rights universal method suffrage
public people access public
transportation public accommodation no
tomorrow so how on earth did a Belgian
cigar maker end up there presumably that
route passion all the signatory of a
letter or anticipated at Maximo Gomez
would wonder that so he explains and
this is the last day of the letter that
I'll read born in France in 1841 by a
Malaysian descent as both my father and
mother were born and good
in the beginning of this century
that's another signal because the court
felt important but I need in the
beginning of the 19th century is the
nation nation set up in New Orleans
after the Revolution my father although
in modest circumstances led Louisiana
for France with the only object in view
of raising the six sons in a country
where no infamous laws or stupid
prejudices could prevent them from
becoming a man so we realized here that
this cigar maker is signaling to Maximo
Gomez a kind of shared commitment to
anti racism he's signaling shared
military experience although and once my
focus was a great general and anyone at
all was a mere a listed man and so as I
read through the letter copy the
transcribed it brought it home to
Michigan the question really arose could
you have see inside this letter and then
inside whatever the story was behind the
letter a long 19th century that had a
somewhat different are stories like one
of the long 19th century we generally
places ending points from the French
Revolution to World War one but here was
a link to the long 19th century with a
Caribbean frame from the Haitian
Revolution
to the cross racial anti-racist human
war of independence
so as the curviness I was intrigued I
put aside the other research I was meant
to be doing and started trying to figure
out first answer the one question was
every kind of normal just lie I mean it
would have made a good story for him
whether it's true or not so I went to
Eric Foner's voluble on members of the
constitutional conventions there was a
short little training
vertical-align:bottom
so went back to his interventions and
the convention is so short off the story
started to check out so the question
then became what kinds of things might
want being to see if one were able to
piece together the generations of this
family so the first question would be
here we have an essentially unknown man
activist but it appears to have a very
strong and transnational race
consciousness and anti racism would it
be possible in part because he's an
unknown figure to get some sense of
vernacular origins of that kind of race
consciousness and figure out what the
content was of his transnational vision
and the second question would be is it
is there some way to to fit the story
around the Caribbean and
at the same time so that we're looking
at the small relatively small triangle
defined by Haiti Cuba and New Orleans
but then were also pregnant and what he
is already reaching for and we know
which is across the Atlantic to France
so they headed to a little couple of
calculations of the thinking fashion for
941 so he was alive for the French
Revolution of 1848 was very old on the
other hand can we begin to pick up
various threads of elements that we
think of as that Atlantic history of
race consciousness so another element of
this would be can be elements of the
memory of Haiti that are not they now
somewhat cliche the location of the
specter of Haiti or the night or the
volcano and all these kinds of cliches
that are used to describe white planters
image of Haiti but instead here we have
someone who made a piece of commercial
correspondence in 1899 is saying I am a
patient descent the last piece that I
was hoping for was that we might be able
to link it quite directly to Cuba
because we know that most of the South
American refugees who ended up in New
Orleans were not the wave of planters
who fled abolition these were people who
left a decade later in response to the
invasion of sound okay and they went
first to Santiago Cuba so the pieces in
effect were there potentially we started
to dig the first find and then I'll just
hand it over to Jean the first find was
to start to pull the thread of Edward
Collins own history to locate his
parents marriage contract in the
notarial archives in New Orleans to make
up a cross reference from the marriage
contract to a document called
rectification of the name of the spouse
and in that document to find a copy of
the baptismal record of Edwards mother
and about Jindal represent whose mother
lists the name of Edna's grandmother and
she was named was Eddie and she was
displayed in Germany in Sunderland so at
that point we realized we could reach
back to the 1780s in West Africa
and then try to pull straight forward
what am i a hit TV show
so the this collaboration of course was
because it was specific being to people
through extensive versatility to look at
a lot of current location for tax and
also to be a strong station
because which is servicing this book is
that we at the beginning the workings of
that that quickly the family others
ultimate because we are speaking of them
and hostage
to speak with them and of course we had
a lot of archives themselves but none
another Lee's art and just to
introducing through this will received
just one month ago
very nice makeover students from the
value just writing to see our you know I
have a descendent of federal inertial
and thank you so much to explaining that
my family is not coming from Mexico
coming from
so that was part of it and I just read a
letter from from in well we could mean
that the movement of this art innovation
was from the Gulf and in the North
America at the end of the 19th century
still in this course any society and
with us is difficult leading with this
possibility suspected and to come to
Europe and
we constructs and movement assist we
have movement from bad to good
in fact doctors at all and which is
interesting is to season all these
people of the same family
well permanently playing with
relationship to each country and we can
see in the modern way without
citizenship so it was it was you know it
was it was change day after day and from
speaking to summary to speak into
another one it was only changing this
relationship with nature with
the synergy and so on so what is really
interesting properties focused on the
possibility is that this is true
vividly in national territory to install
these directories because it wasn't
positive when studies this week in large
land open to on television on the
circulation and to hospice what is in
relationship in a way for them in 19th
century without nations so when you look
at each one was trying to reinvent a
manner to be in this
evil was trained we French ass into the
First Amendment to confirm that was
refreshed
what was his but the druid was surely
and
Ellis was going to be better and twist
monitor the procedure she general the
one which he usually didn't vote but to
be Alexis right so ooh where they that
was really really people to understand
it and to intercultural but I think that
if I take it what we know
so it was was certainly in each woman
important of his life was able to say I
consciousness
I am completely somebody not a citizen
but somebody involved and I think that
when we speak of the Easter cities in
France before this freshness just but of
course when you write in Europe in your
knees doing this you are immediately you
behave so many many words and
you know the other side because
French descendants of French immigrant
from Haiti in this moment so here it was
immediately Sun be different some years
after just after the convention in 68 we
just said I will become a human that in
this world the US France just
coming back to something different
something which is not energy which is
not money to be in a matter of history
in its making so I think that we deserve
very interesting and fascinating in this
family its capacity to you know in work
was very clearly the world in
construction what in which issue country
was trying to
you go home a little ways and to be each
time participants and not follow and so
I just can
to say that when we watch this move I
think for us we were in a way we think
in completely what is to do an Atlanta
and this only help us to change our mind
and to think about territory in a very
different manner
anything you to potentially but as we
change you have a whole culture
I'm gonna do some nose
so the book is just come out but it's
like reading everywhere to children
false and I think that is nice we open
it little bit bored by the both of the
density of the research that this
represents it's so huge but also the
work of imagination
so Rebecca's cousin Johnny have pieced
together from fragments resources
dispersed and archives all over the
Atlantic woman the history of a family
from the late 18th century to the late
19th century with a made 20th century at
Lafayette
holy narrative is accompanied by a
reconstruction of the much wider
political and social dynamics in which
this family
so it is at the same time of micro
history as an Atlantic mackerel history
and it combines the imperative the
ambitions intellectual ethical
so I think that despite the now
long-established imperatives of Atlantic
history many most of us still work in
some ways within the balance of the
national history and more particularly
within the bounds of linguist
history whether you know English French
Spanish Portuguese
we don't pay preserves in this regard a
rare exception so they mentioned the
author's draw on sources Huber and
morning
oh yeah
so getting the time so short I think
what I want to do is just touch quickly
on what for me here's some of the
and I think a lot of what I'm going to
say has to do with my admiration for the
way in which this book brings together
things that are usually separate so
brings together different kinds of
historical question
so pretty maybe through the work of
Atlantic or global history I would also
characterize it as an important for a
into trans colonial history
so the the movements the migrations that
are discussed not just between colonies
of metropoliz
but mom berries
I think this kind of decent ratings very
important in it
but it also you know it has some very
direct consequences I am thinking for
example about the first part of the book
marry me as someone who's primarily
works in Franklin was one of the
discussions that Sean who loved me
and you know particularly the
discussions are slaveholders who are
themselves people of African descent all
of that is quite
context but that is going to confront a
set of readers who are much more
familiar with a North American context
of different kinds
colonial historiography different norms
and different expectations about history
of slavery are are juxtaposed here in a
very fresh
so this is definitely a book about these
three slavery and emancipation I think
it's also a book about the history of
migration immigration immigration and
all of the attendant
simulation integration diaspora
formation community formation angry
questions that have generally not
integrated into history
slavery
it's also I think the history and if you
gesture to this little bit of nationhood
and the evolution of nationality and the
documentary history of nationality so in
we follow the family you are several
generations in the first stage they live
in a world in which many people are
essentially stateless and the most
important documents for them are ones
that have tested their social condition
are they free three akashi or
later on
nationality that attested that national
identity become
and here as the emergency of the nation
states
it is a work legal history but also in a
much broader and richer science I work
on the history of legal culture the
members of the National family clearly
regards the letter of the law as very
changeable and not very transportable
on the other hand they recognize from
very early on immediately I think but
the possession of written documents
notarized if possible will be helpful
even if the law changes or even if the
law is not recognized in another
jurisdiction so that accounts that
legalized and frankly I would say that
is a literary literary training a very
much appreciated books and persist on
the role of categories labels the modes
of representation
ready to change across time that
disappeared sometimes to reappear I
expected
the role of America the way in which the
barriers of intentionality recount their
biography over County history of
economics sometimes retro physics to you
to improve matters pretty they have a
sense that there are narratives they
want to try to another
so I appreciate that very much the
interplay of a social political family
history and a reflection on the world of
representations so you know for my
questions
I guess that I'd like to ask a little
bit
our genealogy genealogical impulse the
quest for news which has been very
important in the North America and
public history of slavery has advertised
by the attorney series with supply once
towards and really getting to the
amusement of our French students
who
you know she'd be about a quest for
boots that were taken back for Africa
this is very moment of deep
linearization of all the history right
so I mean I'm just wondering
whether stays the genealogy is you
genealogy you know I guess typically
goes from memory to document and you are
interested in both and documented
memories of sometimes document allow you
to
about baptismal names but a very moving
moments in which it's hypothesized that
the thing that baby was given reverts
back to a lost sibling in consent and so
the friend at the kind of genealogy
and my other question I guess is how how
to use either birth fitting into the
historiography
to focus
the work of the ones you do I have taken
obviously undecided as righteousness
consciousness recent work I think German
Hopkins
much more highly
so given the kind of micro history that
you - I'm wondering how you see
and so I
come to this with actually first-hand
experience of a
we did exchange some information and so
the research I
we
ownership history of the house in
southwestern France and
and I run across
that's in global sellers of that house
for owners of the house but where
residents some of them were business
okay
and I wanted
who the heck is and so it's sort of the
same people subscribe
research work and it took me
and butt
something I noticed is that there's a
nice to the book that is a history of
the research itself so the research
itself has a history and sort of an
interesting one and and was what your
mom called me and made me an honest one
but this type of research probably would
not have been possible what you need
we together history like this in sort of
the earth the the power of random fights
make us both Google searches or
requirement bulletin boards of general
because you have to
and one one
we might not have about a man and said
that this was part of the history of
migrations one thing that struck me
looking at
don't actors is that these migration
networks cover a lot of ground
Geographics they cover
countenance
they concerned they they concerned the
surprisingly small universe of people
smoke each other talking about
century that's no more than 20
people three colors in New Orleans today
18 century that's what you want
and then it goes up precisely windows
from sandbag
but those but these are smooth and these
are face-to-face communities these
people all knew each other and they
probably knew each other's families
family history and in fact I at some
point I was ready to bet
but which is and and need stretch
migrants to the common experience there
was that aghast is running the same
interview faces they had
this is amazing
and of course the Balkans in us these
were China chain migration networks and
and they they came from the same places
and they went the same basis
across the so I have
a couple of questions and these are open
open-ended question I wonder what it
needs to do
like like this what is what is
transmitted
with his not
generations and if you think about the
different analogues I can think of some
money's contain that tells news stories
across several generations
and so it sort of - oh that is a lot of
this this story and the other question
which is actually related
first so this is in many ways of the
work of historical anthropology but also
in some ways the works of the work of a
quality report because meter cube the
descendants so there is more information
and and I have to experience I played
the sentence
I was at work and it was Andy she tried
an experiment which was to ask them what
they knew without without saying
to contaminate the experiment and it was
really interesting to see
very fragmentary information that goes
through the generations so so some
accurate some not some some distorted
and and of course I had to write it down
because the moment I thought and then of
course the memories and so so I wonder
if you went through the same
and and and of course there are two
characters in your story who are
especially
if I recall say she she thinks she is
originally from Mexico and the same time
she says I have and so there's some sort
of the very sense that she could have an
attitude that you say between witness
no but maybe somehow I so that that's
that's that's an interesting that's an
amazing question and and of course the
the the the the awareness of his
longtime a story that defining some
issues although
because I remember who doesn't have
information and practice of the name
so so how memories is transmitted from
from one generation to the next and
fourteen generations is in itself an
interesting question
and testifies to the special benefits of
collaborative work
finding collaborations which historians
typically are allergic in towards there
are two professional
the authors here good news they're
really good they're very different
they also mobilize other scholars and
insensitive families the way to
understand that sort of adding sort a
little bit of evidence here of
contributions they're significantly
shaping the final
get a chance to talk about so it's quite
appropriate actually that the
traditional acknowledgement section is
an acknowledgments and collaboration
title I think that's major variables
every what that what that means three
different examples perhaps most obvious
Lisbon said full problems of Atlantis
world surpassing its reach and the
connections that identify
that passes any of that name history but
that sequence of departures and arrivals
from Senegal South East point of a
single name the scent of cinnamon
England two votes with Warland and
southern France back New Orleans to
Veracruz to mobile to hinge work to
London and then finest the slave labor
and death camps at ravensbrck
and then also the unnamed
Tangletown okay these movements take
place against the backdrop of war on
revolution so we have here sidewalk
individual lands
Horo in Senegal Valley
Spanish Wars for the 1848 revolution in
France the u.s. Civil War the French
invasion of Mexico and then the
interpretive invasion of Belgium during
World War two
it's not quite right to refer to these
as the backdrop sense for the top shelf
and that these prices represent moments
of rupture of opportunity and perhaps
most consistent moments of transition in
the history of the family although
sometimes it'll say whether the apparent
link between political crisis and war
and the shooting family forces are
always caused by war in evolution but
weather-worn revolution generate the
documents that make study of key moments
in the family's history possible I think
some further thought I'd be given to the
sorts of records that rewards
and how he's prepared with moments of
peace the mobility on display here is
social as well as physical mobility if
the trajectory through the distances
upward from slavery distinct domains who
as a backward fortune three generations
later
the series of reversals near bankruptcy
bill enterprises along the way suggest
that the ultimate fortune was in some
respects fortunately one is invited in
several opening vignettes that the story
of Congress in the agency
19th century Atlantic world but
sometimes one a gradual decline or even
catastrophic loss not always the steady
accumulation well and with the story of
mobility because an extended rumination
throughout on the complexities and
ambiguities of citizenship rebirth
Network insurance is all born in France
but not a French citizen who emigrated
to the US and declared his American
citizenship while keeping evidence of
French nationality under lock and key
the winds light as a Belgian citizen and
then there's his older brother
for New Orleans largely raised in France
proclaimed and recognized as a Mexican
citizen before settling imagine
examples multiplied across the world
from what respective this can quietly
Chronicle of statelessness or an attempt
to secure and by nationality but what
becomes rather more clear at least to me
just how slippery up for grabs
definitions of citizenship and
nationality were across the law of 19th
century but all the best that I'm those
taken by this work as a contribution to
families perhaps in part because the
history
as if Eric so Portland and what falls
under the rubric of the history of the
Atlantic world there are a number what
might be described now as reference once
we refer to that history
maybe lettering volumes and collected
essays in various forms the pets say
perhaps the most probably the most
recent they're the Oxford history dr.
Hanlon
that world published just a year ago
what's remarkable about all of these
works is how history as a subject as a
cat
that ought to be thought about
the other mystery
very good I said by Carol Shama super
acceleration North America that tries to
provide a little bit of a synthesis for
household household formation in merica
what's most remarkable about that essay
is how little she has to synthesize and
try to think about the history of family
what we have
at all our families in particular places
for the human senses family networks
spread across a few places but rarely if
ever in an intergenerational story one
that pursues relations and memory
and there are many payoffs here to
mention the only one is quite clear to
the capacity of the family to survive
the insecurities of their commercial
better in the 19th century depending on
the size and extent of it Spencer
interpersonal networks the capacity
localized capital and friendships hidden
down across the generations
this in turn direct attention to the
household the unit of analysis critical
I know too much work on these for
slavery in that space but it adequately
developed I believe the study of slavery
in the Caribbean much of the fascination
in the first part of the book at least
we need to rise for the picture what
truly categorized as master slave
relations the same to make soup in New
Orleans the late 18th early 19th century
while the most important year offends
whatever notion that term master intense
labor relations Testament book so we're
reminded of the extent of slave holding
by many and here are particularly women
and there's a wonderful wonderful
advance of
probably over the slave owners as
controllers of capital
with North America
and there are these astonishing it's
their purchases that a spouse a child
and a mother-in-law to man man
mentha and their astonishing instances
in Asia of three with a boolean army
insane domain threaten to restore
slavery and Mike Michael
to our family
rosalie his partner though she was no
longer as slight as they have this
interesting moment where a man
commissioned document is made out for
woman's effectively espoused to liberate
her because the fears of the restoration
of slavery unless there are actually
clear manumission document once my
status is going to be
so many missions was in fact not a slur
but my cucumis late in the future was a
kind of award
and I really think it encourages us to
really carefully think about what these
documents often these documents are
operated elsewhere the to teach it in
creative ways that the sort of our
categories
what what about this work is it refusal
to be taken in by the familiar
Alyce's to reject the assumptions that
we don't were talking about when we
perturb racial designations status
designations citizenship designation
these have meetings within this work
that are fluid evolving creatively
strategically to fly and discard that's
necessary so what I do have an extended
appreciation
but long part about sort of tell
my way
yes
one I guess what a meta question
all the products of all there's a
welcome actually refusal to provide a
conclusion
no distillation of submarine now the
sort of conclusion that kind of brings
it all together be close with an
epilogue without the family in the 20th
century and then ends not roughly I
think perhaps prematurely this is one of
those very rare works of history that
what my wish was even longer
she's left wanted to know more about the
branches and more about disorder
specialist in the 20th century Lex's
conclusion
the silence in some ways but what we are
to make of this might happen to the
morals and this is some of the other
ways I'm very happy to be here to talk
about it for many reasons I've known
Rebecca stop for quite a while nobody's
really counting I know John John's wife
a lot longer than he has a perfect right
to it student history professor
and I may be the first person who
actually taught this book right after it
came out and I was teaching thanks to
the PF course I was teaching it a little
master's program at Reed Hall last May
in history and literature and I decided
to give this book to read because it
does involve France as well as the rest
of the Atlantic world so I it's been on
my mind for for a long time one of the
advantages of this advantage of coming
class was the number of things I was
going to say everybody was said by the
panelists I could repeat them all I do
want to point out a few aspects of the
book that are most striking to me first
of all as we heard it is a truly
Atlantic history and it's you know that
is important because as Chris said we
Atlanta is much more often talked about
than done and especially by historians
literary people take one novel for
friends and went from
the documentation and the story of this
particular family is contextualized
within an introduction to the history of
West Africa the slave trade the Haitian
Revolution the Cuban water independence
the American Civil War reconstruction
and many other aspects of 19th century
history the one question one might ask
which of course is asked that world
micro history if that's what I call this
is the question of typicality or
representativeness there's one question
is having before that the authors do not
claim that this family tree is quote
typical whatever exactly that may mean
they just seem rather exceptional
someone is in there incredible array of
movements and law
relations and places that ended up in
businesses about the paper maybe maybe
not in that world more interesting to me
is this question which the book's title
suggests which is documents the
importance of physical documents these
freedom papers the book is actually
currently focused on really a handful of
four or five or six or something key
documents produced in various places in
Haiti in Cuba in the United States and
elsewhere and what these mean about how
these documents are the anchors of this
family's quest for rights for
nationality for freedom in some cases
the importance of these paper documents
it also suggests it also is an
interesting illustration of the
difference between kind of a Franco and
Spanish origin society and the United
States these places are full of people
who we have no equivalent to here
notaries there's all of the places
notaries and you can go to them with a
document get them to fill it out
that's not all there's a little piece of
the culture that to Americans seems
oddly odd but the notary is very
important if you want to a document to
actually have weight of course they also
indicate that at least one of these
documents was quite lightly forged
actually by the by members of this
family in order to advance claims to
freedom etc I think that I want to talk
for a minute about what this doctor what
this book tells us about one little
piece of it which is reconstruction of
the United States because as Rebecca
started that's where she just began
really with this man talking about we've
been in this legislative Constitutional
Convention eternity we tend to you know
when we talk about the abolition of
slavery it is Reconstruction period we
tend to for good reason talk about the
origins of those ideas in a sort of
anglo-american context you know
who writes the Declaration of
Independence or evangelical
Protestantism as the sort of roots of
anti-slavery radicalism but here we have
in New Orleans a different trajectory
into the reconstruction struggle for
equal rights which is coming out of a
French heritage an Asian Revolution and
the French Revolution of the French
Revolution of 1848 and it's got a
slightly different language than the
Anglo view of reconstruction and as
Rebecca knows we're ending this book it
flows up to the core of this question of
what she has called public rights with
the Louisiana Constitution of 1867 or 68
elevates this notion of public rights
far above any other state constitution
of radical reconstruction but we need my
public rice is not just the right to
vote not just the right to equal
opportunity to labor not just the
equality before the law equality in
treatment in the public sphere that is
to say the ability to go on
transportation equally into places of
public accommodation to be treated in
public venues without racial inequality
and that's that is really the push very
hard by this free Negro group in New
Orleans now the book actually lead to
lead us to think more about that it's a
small number of people is SPSA but they
had a rather large impact in some ways
on the development of radical
reconstruction
others needed one example Abraham
Lincoln's first in Grace of black
suffrage in a limited way came as a
result of meeting with two delegates not
your man but two delegates from free
Negroes from New Orleans in 1864 they
came to the White House and they said
they look like a new government being
created in Louisiana Louisiana
occupied by a new anti-slavery
government is being created but they're
not giving us any rights and we have
certainly as quality are properly
educated we have as much qualification
to vote as these white people do in fact
more than one and they actually said you
know you're right
and he sent a letter to the governor and
military Conner
of Louisiana saying I think you want to
let in to vote the quote-unquote very
intelligent blacks as these very people
so you know they are putting this onto
the national agenda and they are what
they're doing in New Orleans is being
noticed by people like Charles Sumner
Thaddeus Stevens Radical Republicans in
Congress so this is a this is not all
exactly in the book but I think it
should lead us to think more broadly
about the role of that particular group
in in the history of radical radical
reconstruction now as an increase the
sort of indicated I mean the other
interesting thing about the book is how
it sort of destabilizes a lot of the
categories we take for granted and we
have to take a break but we talk in big
generalized terms about slavery
emancipation freedom that's when we talk
about race relations and fire but all
those things are very complicated when
it comes to a single family and there's
no trajectory there's no
from slavery to freedom and in fact it's
possible to go back the other way we've
got media freedom something they come
along and put you back into slavery just
depending on both the the fortunes of
war and the fortunes of politics slaves
polished in ad that is reestablished at
least the French try to reestablish it
and the status of people is always
rather ambiguous and of progress and
that's one of the reasons that these
documents are so important in one family
there are often slaves and slave owners
free people slaves all related to each
other and people complain multiple
nationalities people that contradictory
or conflicting political views people
engaged in economic partnerships who
then later sue each other for money you
know it was like any family they were
always fighting with each other
as well as trying to try to move ahead
so and and the whole question which is
sort of kind of cliche of agency is very
interesting in here how is actually
exercised agency is not just a act of
rebellion these people you these people
rebelled at various times they they they
confront the state but they also use the
system they use what the system offers
to them they work we need to gain
advantages for themselves as well as
sort of resistance in a kind of abstract
way I just want to conclude by saying
that that people have mentioned the
ending and I think it is a wonderful and
it may be nice to have more of a human
breaking
but it ends with you know kind of really
on an interesting story of one of the
descendants here a controversy over
whether women marry a Belgian white man
or a Belgian man but they couldn't marry
that because he was known to have this
some African guada so they went to Great
Britain where lovers to do anything they
want as they got married in Great
Britain in 1937 and it was sort of cause
celeb about that having to flee to
Britain in order to get married and then
in World War two she here's where the
historical irony or trajectory comes
full-circle this woman went back
development to join the resistance she
was captured and she was put into a
slave labor camp not an extermination
camp they slit so she's suddenly back in
slavery two centuries after her ancestor
was removed from West Africa
into slavery in the New World and she
died they ever met is all controversy
about whether she can be recognized as
someone who was a victim of the Nazis
for political reasons or for racial
remembering of course it's a long
complicated debate that in Belgium but
then I I may have the genealogy slightly
wrong because I that was a long time ago
or a year ago that hard order is today
living in Africa so the story goes full
circle from Rosa Lee who was picked up
in West Africa and brought to Haiti and
to sent musa so later her great-great
great-great-great endure as a free woman
of her own choice is living back in
africa
let me give my own question we were all
told to his presence one of the very
interesting things about this book is
that the authors speculate a lot they do
not try to front over the fact that
there are big gaps in this documentary
record five or six documents cannot tell
you the whole story and they they
speculate
well this may this may be the case oh we
think monthly this was the case so I
just would like to hear a little more
about how they thought about speculating
which is something to start in stride I
think not to do we might just seem like
we're certain of everything we say we're
not you know how do you would fit
speculation when you might well be wrong
it's a guesswork into a revolution and I
think in some ways the Cystic was
programmed placement down in history and
that are evoked with the complexities
family it part of the answer to that
question that the useful way of
narrating the Haitian Revolution which
is to move these puzzle pieces called
visual the slaves the uprising the
planners the called all of the team
dollars as you get closer and closer the
interconnections between people could be
put in those categories and then the way
you move in and out of those categories
please not just as a beautiful
invocation of we actually learn the
whole but without ever using the word
fluidity because these headers squat for
me it's that the Templars themselves are
just playing interact with an unstable
and
historians would be awfully careful
before we use them so that sense that we
can describe groups and they even though
we could have somehow thought of family
it was typical by knowing our inori what
the most common groups were mentioned
that's exactly the opposite of this
approach we assume the categories are
not priorities such as they don't need
to mcnally even want typicality the
discipline for this story came from the
fact that we knew almost nothing about
the famine when we started but anything
they did we had to explain and that may
explain things we never even would have
thought it was going to be included in
history and evolution so I think that's
what made that particular exciting
on the question of speculation and
collaboration and whether there would be
more and so on let me just say order to
this is this is a complex collaboration
and the book is actually entirely
rewritten in French by my colleague and
you will notice that the word forgery is
not here in the English edition our our
understanding is that each one has the
veto in his or her name language and I
do like the word get into this edition
title I say that the family cause
documents to be brought into existence
which can be the privilege
either of going to a notary and having a
notary draw a conceptual understanding
that's perfectly legitimate now
sometimes there was no dog notary and
sometimes it was the contradiction is
1802 free of the manumission paper this
makes no sense but it's something it's
all these different forgeries actually
created by all the people named in it
and signed by the man who actually wrote
it but it's evoking as you say I went to
civil authorities in Haiti and had the
original for a specific person registry
copy and she took it with her we find
all those enemies the National who died
more probably in 1787 and who as she's a
war refugee who sent oh man definitely
during the Revolution that did Santiago
she put her daughter on a boat for New
Orleans and they start my godmother and
she was that he went back to Haiti the
only country and the American in the
plantation America where she could be
sure freedom citizenship and then almost
25 years later we found her on a
passenger list on a boat coming from
to the world almost certainly carrying
that officially certified copy of birth
registry with her so that her daughter
could go to a notary bring documenting
the existence that would attest to the
back of the daughter has her name she
would say my father because we had birth
even remarried my mother wouldn't
recognize me at birth so I have a last
name her daughter never had a last name
before and then a kind of twist against
this hate sure that we're so familiar
with of elite my skin free people of
color are bilingual in New Orleans who
does this family choose as the godmother
at the baptism of of eight men in 1836
they ask what they need to stand at the
baptismal font it's under control as the
godmother for one of her own
grandchildren which means the fact that
there was that leaf born in Senegal be
it means that the family of her daughter
and husband who in some sense are in
that category of artisan that makes man
history are actually choosing the
African political protection
so so the book will be a little bit
different when it comes out in French
and it will also enable us to add some
things that we only discovered since it
came out so we just realized a lot of
pieces together that one of Edwards ever
touched all those young men who wrote
the letter it's all of whom of the
letter but who circulates for his
closest business associate a man named
Arthur career Amish and we just realized
he's a member of the committee of
citizens for work the separate carcasses
any help support the challenge in Plessy
versus Ferguson
so that means that every time saw in the
years that he wrote that letter to Gomez
he's receiving the news from Louisiana
first of the campaign for operation
campaign in support Homer Plessy and
then the loss of the Supreme Court which
crushes the public rights tradition in
Louisiana so there will be more because
and each time well why
and we know that it was invented at the
end of the night essentially question of
the white side up with this provision
what is wrong is the question of the
somebody writing this out what is wrong
is it something so in a community with a
lot of Earthlings and
within these well then so how to as
history and who to work on this on this
network
people need by what four wishes in my
work and I think that
you have come to the question of the
typicality what why is that an
interesting funny story because it's a
manner in which history coming back to a
Jewish people in its centrality and to
transform of illness and the manner in
which they not only lacked
revision of that and the family youth of
course other groups and family Andrew
say better than four years for Percy
trilogy sir fallacy matter better need
to exchange and white in that is really
important so yes because of the
construction of the memory and because
he said this successive great in the
reality that median
situation
the marker the imagination closes
anything that there is more clean up for
the first chapter
you have to be a fertile imagination
greater I just got and seeing that it's
actually very kind of the best treatment
from the bigger and you know I was
worried to see that's where world
remember this conversation but when I
presented a very early paper that wasn't
me you came up and said Oh Rebecca any
time you're working or doing you've
divided their sections using the classic
19th century novelist a technique and it
works very well as a what technique is
that and you said oh well it's clear
you've opened these chapter within
arrived at the section as soon as you
vote in each section with an arrival and
you closed it with the departure and I
think at that moment we we talked about
it and realized okay that is what we
will try to do throughout the book maybe
a little exception when we get to
reconstruction because it's very dense
material so up until but not including
the epilogue it has this spatial
arrival/departure
feel to it which I guess works because
this is the fiction writers of 19th
century were writing the serial later
learn that is it works well with our
psyches that readers because we want to
turn the next page and see if I have
that so for example terms of categories
genetic national these France never have
we been marked by color as the boat
lands and he settles in New Orleans he
remarked at noon aha so those kinds of
things worked well now the other log we
never anticipated right we thought the
walkway end the plan was that the book
would begin with Edwards letter to Gomez
explaining the story and then we would
go to the whole in 1899 and then it
would reach all the way back to whether
his birth in Senegambia and then through
sentiment worth and we would then come
back to the letter at the end as we
reach 1899 at which point the letter
would have a different meaning for the
reader because instead of being a
curiosity it would now be a closure and
that's how it was going to end and then
we learned about not using tension and
we just learned this small piece which
was the contested marriage in England
Martha Jones found a reference to that
and we tracked that I mean okay well
this will enable us to end with 1937
when the issue a raishin with race and
racial designation is taking on a new
meaning in the 20th century so the
barrier of her marriage has that echo is
37 London is the Vino colored people's
it's a moment of great radicalism so we
thought that would be the law and so
then we asked the family could you just
clarify for us
they installers she exactly even though
she's one of the great grandchildren and
they said oh well if you want to know
about that I should say with me to talk
to all spots so we booked up all spots
and she said well if you wonder what I
should say you need to you need to sleep
in the shade so this book to me said
enemy shed said we've never understood
she Michelle's mother was a six-year-old
at the time that when we were explained
and he shows responsibly was I had a lot
of documents your historians what
happened and so the project took another
two years because we realized at that
point that our reciprocal relationship
with the family was such that once we
may ask
and part of the reason they do so little
speculation again is that when you're
writing about participation in the
resistance against the Nazis in Belgium
everybody is always pretty supposed to
think that you're exaggerating and then
it's just family memory and there are
many claims that there was resistance so
that the epilogue or that anything else
page locked down so it wasn't fatherly
to the critique that they were being
drawn into a family memory and then
genres and drugs for concentration Kevin
actually the staff at the camp are
preparing a small in fact 170 government
we have right over stuff and we factor
with that and in a way the last this
chapter the you know I see it as the
same because we are no documents really
these
and so on so it's interesting to see
that beginning in the society and in the
reconstruction of society by the Nazi
archivist in a way disappear in the same
the same manner you know it's a it's
very much wider this way of body what
you say because we have aperitivo
not of this way and in the same history
of violence but they they weren't they
weren't as if I did not spread okay